Hey, Alex!
嘿，亚历克斯！
Remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about.
你知道我正在谈论的那个人。
The red, white, and blue ones.
有红的、白的、蓝的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
They pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds.
他们几乎统治着附近的游泳池和游乐场。
Your face should be covered with your finger.
你的脸应该用手指遮住。
It was just a delightful summer memory.
这只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
Well, five-hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and reimagined it as a bold, refreshing, freeze energy shot every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion like the original pops of which you speak expertly blending juicy cherry citrusy lime and sweet blue raspberry to completely ignite your taste buds it's that fruity taste that you crave created with zero sugar so you can enjoy the full experience guilt-free.
嗯，五小时能量将这种标志性的怀旧情绪重新想象成一种大胆、清爽、冻结的能量，每一口都能带来巨大的风味爆炸，就像你所说的原始流行音乐一样，熟练地混合多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜美的蓝色覆盆子，完全点燃你的味蕾，这是你渴望的零糖创造的果味味道，这样你就可以毫无愧疚地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, head it out on a weekend road trip or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决下午在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味感觉。
This portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
这款便携式镜头是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouthwatering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework freeze flavored five-hour energy shot now available online at fivehourenergy.com or or Amazon.
现在可以在 Fivehourenergy.com 或 Amazon 上购买烟花冷冻口味的五小时能量饮料，点燃您的味蕾。
Hi, it's Paola from Italy.
嗨，我是来自意大利的保拉。
The first time I watched Elmater Madder was during the first wave of COVID that came March of 2020.
我第一次看 Elmater Madder 是在 2020 年 3 月第一波新冠疫情期间。
My name is Josh.
我叫乔什。
I first watch the show as a college student in New York.
我第一次看这个节目时还是纽约的一名大学生。
My name is Anna.
我叫安娜。
I am in Los Angeles, planet Earth.
我在地球洛杉矶。
How I met your mother is special because whether I've had a fantastic day or a f***ing terrible day, watching that show is always the right move for the mid.
我遇见你母亲的方式很特别，因为无论我度过了美好的一天还是糟糕透顶的一天，观看那个节目始终是中间的正确选择。
My friend told me to watch the show and just said I'm Ted Mosby.
我的朋友叫我去看这个节目，并说我是泰德·莫斯比。
I had no idea what he was talking about.
我不知道他在说什么。
And I watched it and I came back to him and I said, mm-hmm, I'm Ted Mosby.
我看了它，然后我回到他身边，我说，嗯嗯，我是特德·莫斯比。
You remember, it was her time with strict lockdowns and isolation.
你记得，那是她严格封锁和隔离的时期。
After a very tough day, every night, I watched some of my episodes to, let's say, hope I come such difficult times.
在经历了非常艰难的一天之后，每天晚上，我都会观看一些剧集，希望我能度过这样艰难的时刻。
It feels right, regardless, to go spend time with those characters.
不管怎样，花时间和这些角色在一起感觉是对的。
Those Candid, stumbling, hilarious, raunchy, relentlessly then selves people.
那些坦率、跌跌撞撞、热闹、不修边幅、毫不留情的人。
And that gives the same feeling, the same quality of what good friendship is.
这与良好的友谊有着同样的感觉和品质。
And being between junior and senior year of college, I was terrified of what was coming next and how to make it happen the way I wanted.
在大学三年级和四年级之间，我对接下来发生的事情以及如何让它按照我想要的方式发生感到恐惧。
Then there was this wonderful show that was all about how the randomness of life is what gets you exactly where you need to be.
然后有一个精彩的节目，讲述的是生活的随机性如何让你准确地到达你需要去的地方。
I'm a low movie soon in New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
我很快就会在纽约市拍电影，当我见到你时，请允许我告诉你在纽约市的一切。
Well, hello, hello, this is Josh Radner.
嗯，你好，你好，我是乔什·拉德纳。
I am here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hi, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Josh.
乔什。
Hey, it's great to be here with you.
嘿，很高兴和你在一起。
Welcome to the first episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》第一集。
Are we calling it Hwimium?
我们称之为 Hwimium 吗？
I was wondering about that.
我对此感到好奇。
Hwimium.
Hwimium。
I think it's Hwimium.
我认为是 Hwimium。
Does it work?
有效吗？
I think it does.
我认为确实如此。
Yeah.
是的。
So how I made your mother, which is the show under discussion, is a show that ran on CBS from 2005 to 2014.
那么我如何创造了你的母亲，也就是我们正在讨论的节目，是2005年至2014年在哥伦比亚广播公司播出的一档节目。
Is that right, Craig?
是这样吗，克雷格？
That is correct.
这是正确的。
Nine seasons.
九个季节。
nine seasons, so almost a decade of our lives.
九个季节，差不多是我们生命的十年。
I played the I and how I met your mother.
我扮演了《我和我如何遇见你母亲》。
I played the character of Ted Mosby for nine seasons and Craig tell us what you did on the show.
我扮演了泰德·莫斯比这个角色九季，克雷格告诉我们你在剧中做了什么。
I was Barney.
我是巴尼。
No, that's right.
不，没错。
I remember that.
我记得。
I have not aged well.
我还没有老好。
If you're watching on the YouTube, no, I'm the co-creator of the show, along with my very brilliant writing partner Carter Bayes who will be a guest on here to discuss future and future episodes and we were lucky enough to create the show that found our way to the likes of you, Mr. Ratner.
如果您在 YouTube 上观看，不，我是该节目的共同创作者，还有我非常出色的写作搭档卡特·贝耶斯（Carter Bayes），他将作为嘉宾在这里讨论未来和未来的剧集，我们很幸运能够制作这个节目，并找到了像拉特纳先生这样的人的方式。
Oh, thanks.
哦，谢谢。
Well, Craig and I have obviously been friends now for coming on two decades, which is astonishing.
嗯，克雷格和我显然已经是二十年来的朋友了，这令人惊讶。
We both now live in New York.
我们现在都住在纽约。
About once a year I would say we have a habit of grabbing a meal or some drinks and talk inevitably turns now.
我想说，大约每年一次，我们都有吃顿饭或喝点饮料的习惯，现在谈话不可避免地会发生变化。
I made my mother as well as other things that are happening in our lives.
我创造了我的母亲以及我们生活中发生的其他事情。
But I so enjoy talking about how I met your mother with you and unpacking this thing we made that has been the biggest gift and has carried a lot of shadow with it.
但我非常喜欢谈论我是如何和你一起认识你母亲的，以及如何拆开我们制作的这个东西，它是最大的礼物，并且带有很多阴影。
And it's just like all things is a very complicated thing, but also a very beautiful thing.
就像所有的事物都是一件非常复杂的事情，但同时也是一件非常美丽的事情一样。
And you're the person I love talking about this show with the most.
你是我最喜欢谈论这个节目的人。
So when this idea struck me like, you know what, it's actually time for me to turn around and revisit how I made your mother, but also watch it a lot of the episodes for the first time.
所以当这个想法让我震惊时，你知道吗，实际上是时候让我转身重新审视我是如何创造你母亲的，但也第一次观看了很多剧集。
I only watched about half the episodes, what it was on.
我只看了大约一半的剧集，内容是什么。
So I will be rewatching the show along with you and our listeners, some of whom I assume will be coming to the show for the first time other ones will have watched it many times and are just looking for the backstage notes here.
因此，我将与您和我们的听众一起重新观看该节目，我认为其中一些人将是第一次来观看该节目，其他人可能已经看过很多次，只是在这里寻找后台笔记。
But I figured if I'm going to do this, why don't we put it on the record and actually just walk through the show together and much like the older wiser narrator, Ted, which we are now around that age, let's look back and see who we were, who we are now, where we're going.
但我想，如果我要这样做，为什么我们不把它记录下来，实际上只是一起走过整个节目，就像我们现在在那个年龄的年长而明智的叙述者泰德一样，让我们​​回顾一下，看看我们是谁，我们现在是谁，我们要去哪里。
And yeah, what else would you say about what we're doing here?
是的，对于我们在这里所做的事情，您还有什么想说的吗？
Well, first of all, I can't believe you only watched half of the episodes.
好吧，首先，我不敢相信你只看了一半的剧集。
I'm deeply offended.
我深感被冒犯。
I think I'm just going to walk off.
我想我要走开。
I'm walking off the project.
我要离开这个项目了。
No, the truth is I haven't rewatched the show door-to-door since it went off.
不，事实是，自从节目播出以来，我还没有挨家挨户地重看过。
I've seen episodes, but I haven't watched a door to door.
我看过几集，但没有挨家挨户看过。
And so I think what we're doing here is excavating back into our past.
所以我认为我们在这里所做的就是挖掘我们的过去。
It was almost a decade of our lives.
这几乎是我们生命中的十年。
And we're trying to figure out what did we do there?
我们试图弄清楚我们在那里做了什么？
What happened?
发生了什么？
We made this thing.
我们做了这个东西。
It's like the pineapple episode.
这就像菠萝情节。
You're like, what?
你就像，什么？
We have to piece it together.
我们必须把它拼凑起来。
We're doing the pineapple incident, but for the entire series.
我们正在制作菠萝事件，但是是整个系列。
What happened?
发生了什么？
We woke up.
我们醒了。
We woke up, we've awakened them.
我们醒了，我们唤醒了他们。
We're almost 50.
我们快50岁了。
We're, I think you're, you're there.
我们，我想你，你就在那里。
And I'm up there almost there.
我就快到了。
And we're kind of going, wait, we are closer to the age of future Ted, we are closer to 2030.
我们正在走，等等，我们离未来 Ted 的时代更近了，我们离 2030 年更近了。
And then we were to do the 2005 when the show launched.
然后我们将在 2005 年节目推出时进行拍摄。
And it is just, it is strange.
这就是，这很奇怪。
I was thinking about the sort of symmetry of it.
我在思考它的对称性。
We are something like, I think, 20 years since the premiere.
我想距首映已有 20 年了。
I think this September will be 20 years since the premiere.
我认为今年九月将是首映20周年。
We are just past 10 years of it, of the finale airing, of it finishing airing.
我们已经过去十年了，它的结局播出，它的结束播出。
So there's a lot of round numbers.
所以有很多整数。
There's a 20 and there's a 10 and here we are, and it just seems like a good moment to kind of look back and take stock of it.
有一个 20，有一个 10，我们就在这里，这似乎是回顾和评估它的好时机。
Yeah.
是的。
I, um, another thing that I, when I called you to talk about this that I really wanted to talk about, I said, I am a stonished one at the, the kind of long tail of the show, you know, a lot of shows go off the air and, and they go off the air.
我，嗯，另一件事，当我打电话给你谈论我真正想谈论的这个问题时，我说，我对这个节目的长尾感到惊讶，你知道，很多节目都停播了，而且它们停播了。
They go away, you know, and maybe they come up randomly in a, I don't know, trivia night or, you know, remember that, a moment will come back to you.
他们会消失，你知道，也许他们会在一个我不知道的琐事之夜随机出现，或者，你知道，记住这一点，一会儿就会回到你身边。
There's something about how I made my mother one.
我是如何让我的母亲成为这样的人的。
It keeps minting new fans.
它不断地吸引新的粉丝。
So people that were babies, children, or even in their teens when it was on have now discovered it.
因此，婴儿、儿童甚至青少年时期的人们现在都发现了它。
I also think there's a really sweet thing.
我也觉得有一个非常甜蜜的事情。
I think parents are showing it to their teenage kids now.
我认为父母现在正在向十几岁的孩子展示它。
They're like, this show taught me a lot about being an adult or a young adult navigating all these things.
他们就像，这个节目教会了我很多关于作为一个成年人或一个年轻人如何应对所有这些事情的知识。
But also, I must punish it in a number of things, but one of the ones that strikes me about when I hear from how I made my mother fan something I hear so consistently that it's not just anecdotal it has to be there has to be something there which is that people say I got turned on to the show or I started watching the show when I was in a really hard moment of my life whether it's you know it's going through a divorce or a sickness or my parent was had died I was having a personal kind of moment of crisis and there seems to be that this thing I've noticed that how I met your mother is like soul medicine for people going through hard times and I don't know that it was conceived of that exactly I don't think you and Carter sat down in 2004 and said I know what we'll do we'll do a soul panacea for people but it seems like that's what it does for people.
但同时，我也必须在很多方面惩罚它，但其中一个让我印象深刻的是，当我听到我如何让我母亲喜欢一些我一直听到的东西时，它不仅仅是轶事，它必须有一些东西，人们说我对这个节目感兴趣，或者我在我人生中一个非常困难的时刻开始观看这个节目，无论是你知道它正在经历离婚或生病还是我的父母已经去世，我正在经历一种个人的危机时刻，似乎有这样的事情，我注意到我如何遇见你母亲就像是经历困难时期的人的灵魂良药，我不知道它是如何构想的，我不认为你和卡特在 2004 年坐下来说我知道我们会做什么，我们会为人们做灵魂灵丹妙药，但似乎这就是它对人们的作用。
And I hear it so consistently that it strikes me as something worth exploring.
我经常听到它，这让我觉得它是值得探索的东西。
It's such an honor.
真是太荣幸了。
People come up to us all the time and to you, Josh, and say the show got them through something really hard.
人们总是来找我们，也来找你，乔什，说这部剧帮助他们度过了一些非常困难的时期。
And getting that, or they say, I married my wife because we realized we're both how much mother fans.
明白了这一点，或者他们说，我嫁给了我的妻子，因为我们意识到我们都是妈妈的粉丝。
So they met in an event or something like it's just the ways the show has been crucial in people's lives.
所以他们是在一次活动或类似的事情中相遇的，这就是节目对人们生活至关重要的方式。
Like the opening words from the fans, We have the greatest fans of any fans.
就像粉丝们的开场白一样，我们拥有所有粉丝中最伟大的粉丝。
How much mother?
妈妈多少钱？
Shout out to the fans.
向粉丝们喊话。
Huge shout out to the fans.
向粉丝们大声喊叫。
If you were listening to this, you were an amazing person.
如果你听到这个，你就是一个了不起的人。
And we, I find such an openness, Josh, to come talk to us about stuff.
乔什，我发现我们非常开放地来和我们谈论事情。
Do you get this?
你明白吗？
I get this a little bit because I'm a writer and people I have to go around telling people I wear a little shirt that says I created how much mother and just on that needy.
我之所以能理解这一点，是因为我是一名作家，我必须四处走动，告诉人们我穿着一件小衬衫，上面写着我创造了多少母亲，只是为了那些有需要的人。
But no one knows.
但没有人知道。
I have a tattooed on my face.
我的脸上有一个纹身。
You have 10 most of you tattooed on your face.
你们大多数人脸上都有纹身。
And I've been dying for years to ask you to ask you, this sort of two-part question, what was it like being Ted when the show was on and blowing up and not being able to escape Ted's face, your face is Ted's face, although you are not Ted.
多年来我一直渴望让你问你，这种由两部分组成的问题，当节目播出并爆炸时，作为泰德感觉如何，无法逃脱泰德的脸，你的脸是泰德的脸，尽管你不是泰德。
And then what has that felt like kind of in the long 10 years since it went off the air?
那么自从它停播以来的漫长十年里，感觉是什么样的呢？
What is it, what has that felt like, like the reason I thought of that is that you just said people come up to you and they share these things with you.
那是什么，感觉如何，就像我想到这一点的原因是你刚才说人们来找你，他们与你分享这些事情。
That seems like a real gift.
这看起来像是一份真正的礼物。
I'm sure there's also like enormous, weird downside.
我确信还有一个巨大的、奇怪的缺点。
It's still like, do a deal.
仍然是这样，做一笔交易。
It's such an interesting episode on being Ted Mosby.
这是关于特德·莫斯比的有趣的一集。
I think there's a lot to unpack that I wouldn't be able to unpack here, but I'll do a little bit.
我认为有很多东西需要解开，但我在这里无法解开，但我会做一点。
I will say this.
我会这么说。
I remember I was writing Liberal Arts for the second film I wrote and directed.
我记得我正在为我自编自导的第二部电影撰写文科课程。
And it was 2009 or 10.
那是2009年或10年。
I think it was 2010.
我认为那是2010年。
And I went to Spain for a month, kicked around Spain, went to about five or six cities, wrote during the day and kind of just got into trouble at night on some level.
我去了西班牙一个月，在西班牙各地闲逛，去了大约五六个城市，白天写作，晚上在某种程度上遇到了麻烦。
I mean, it was just really fun.
我的意思是，这真的很有趣。
And my friend, Horula, introduced me to all her friends who were living in Spain.
我的朋友霍鲁拉把我介绍给她所有住在西班牙的朋友。
So I had like these blind friend dates everywhere when I would leave my hotel or wherever I was staying.
所以当我离开酒店或无论我住的地方时，我都会喜欢这些盲目的朋友约会。
And I would, people, I was just getting recognized in Spain.
我会的，朋友们，我刚刚在西班牙得到认可。
And people would want a picture.
人们想要一张照片。
They want to say, hi.
他们想说，嗨。
But then they'd say, say, do you want to come to a flamenco show in a couple hours?
但他们会说，你想看几个小时后的弗拉门戈表演吗？
And I'd say, yes.
我想说，是的。
And it was like my face was this, like social, I don't know, like the fact that they were familiar with me gave them permission.
就好像我的脸是这样的，就像社交，我不知道，就像他们熟悉我的事实给了他们许可。
It like, it was just this weird social look that I was accepted everywhere.
就好像，正是这种奇怪的社交形象让我到处都被接受了。
I was, one of the things I really loved about it made the world feel much smaller.
我真正喜欢的一件事是，它让世界感觉更小了。
You know, I've always wanted to, not, I don't want to talk to every person I meet, but I do like the feeling that the world is not so big and filled with anonymous scary people because I find people are, most people are quite lovely once you get to know them, once you get over that kind of like, you're strange and different, I don't know who you are, where you're from.
你知道，我一直想，不，我不想和我遇到的每个人交谈，但我确实喜欢这种感觉，世界不是那么大，充满了匿名的可怕的人，因为我发现人们是这样的，大多数人一旦你了解他们，就会变得很可爱，一旦你克服了这种感觉，你就会变得陌生和不同，我不知道你是谁，你来自哪里。
So it gave me like a common language with people.
所以它给了我与人们的共同语言。
I think I've told you this, but in Spain, I went to this little town called Deia and I got really sick, I got food poisoning for the first 24 hours and I crawled out of the place I was staying and I had hooded sweatshirt on that.
我想我已经告诉过你了，但在西班牙，我去了一个叫德亚的小镇，我病得很厉害，在最初的 24 小时里我食物中毒了，我爬出了我住的地方，身上穿着连帽运动衫。
I think was like tied and I was just trying to get like some ginger ale or something and some crackers because I was so I was such a mess and there were like 10 or 12 like young college students.
我想我就像被束缚了一样，我只是想买一些姜汁汽水之类的东西和一些饼干，因为我太乱了，而且有大约 10 或 12 个年轻的大学生。
They were hotel management interns from like all over the world and they recognized me like through my hoodie with this sickness and they were like, oh that's him, let's be vomiting in a bush.
他们是来自世界各地的酒店管理实习生，他们通过我的连帽衫认出了我，他们就像是，哦，那就是他，让我们在灌木丛中呕吐吧。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
And they invited me the next night to either come to to launch your dinner, I forget.
第二天晚上他们邀请我来参加你的晚餐，我忘了。
But I ended up paying out with these hotel management interns for like three or four days.
但我最终还是付给了这些酒店管理实习生大约三四天的费用。
And they were incredible.
他们太不可思议了。
But this one guy owned the bar and we were in Mallorca.
但这家酒吧是这个人开的，而我们在马略卡岛。
And he owned the bar to be clear, not the bar, not the bar that gave you food poisoning.
而且要澄清的是，他拥有这家酒吧，而不是酒吧，不是让你食物中毒的酒吧。
No, no, no, I got food poisoning in another town.
不不不，我在另一个城镇食物中毒了。
He was 23 years old.
那年他23岁。
His dad had just died.
他的父亲刚刚去世。
And so we inherited this bar.
所以我们继承了这个酒吧。
He had never been off the island of Mallorca.
他从未离开过马略卡岛。
One night he hands me a drink and he says, no can do's filled baby doll.
一天晚上，他递给我一杯饮料，他说，没有什么可以做的填充娃娃。
And he knew every single line of how I met your mother.
他知道我如何认识你母亲的每一句话。
That's so amazing.
太神奇了。
And the thing he told me that I thought was so spectacular was he said, how I met your mother has taught me that what's happening now will be my memories one day.
他告诉我的那件事让我觉得非常壮观，他说，我是如何认识你母亲的，这告诉我，现在发生的事情有一天会成为我的回忆。
So make sure that the present moment is great, that you're making good memories for yourself in the present moment.
因此，请确保当下的时刻是美好的，确保你在当下为自己创造美好的回忆。
You know?
你知道？
So beautiful.
如此美丽。
And then these hotel management interns, for some reason, like, you know, they would, they would have a few drinks in them, but they would tell me like their deepest, darkest secrets.
然后这些酒店管理实习生，出于某种原因，比如，你知道，他们会喝一些饮料，但他们会告诉我他们最深、最黑暗的秘密。
Like some shocking stuff.
比如一些令人震惊的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think there was something about, they knew me, they felt like they knew me.
我认为他们了解我，他们感觉他们了解我。
They felt comfortable with it.
他们对此感到很舒服。
Yeah, that's it.
是的，就是这样。
This is not an invitation, by the way, if you're hearing this, to come up to me and tell me Tell you really weird.
顺便说一句，如果你听到这个，这并不是邀请你过来告诉我“告诉你真的很奇怪”。
So let's beat your dishes, let's have boundaries.
所以，让我们打败你的菜，让我们有界限。
But there is something about this, this is the kind of stuff I really love is, it gave me like access to people in a way that made the world feel friendly.
但这是我真正喜欢的东西，它让我能够以一种让世界感到友好的方式接触人们。
That's a beautiful story.
这是一个美丽的故事。
That is a key.
那是一把钥匙。
You have like the skeleton key to let you into doors that would not have been open.
你就像一把万能钥匙，可以让你进入那些原本不会打开的门。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you.
我给你写了这首小曲来唱给你听。
Oh, you look city.
哦，你看起来像城市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Alec, you know what happened to me when I found a good therapist?
亚历克，你知道当我找到一位好的治疗师后我发生了什么吗？
What happened to you when you found a good therapist?
当你找到一位好的治疗师后，你发生了什么？
I married her.
我娶了她。
Oh.
哦。
My wife Jordana is a therapist, a wonderful therapist.
我的妻子乔丹娜是一位治疗师，一位出色的治疗师。
But today we're talking about Rula, which I believe Alec, you have used and can tell us a little more about.
但今天我们谈论的是 Rula，我相信 Alec 您已经使用过它，并且可以告诉我们更多相关信息。
I can and I would like to announce first that I did not marry a single one of the therapist that I have used.
我可以而且我想首先宣布，我没有与我使用过的治疗师结婚。
It's good to say that right up front.
最好提前说清楚。
Disclaimer, yes, no rule is, it's fantastic.
免责声明，是的，没有规则，这太棒了。
It's a way of finding an online therapist and I have used them for years.
这是寻找在线治疗师的一种方式，我已经使用它们很多年了。
It's basically built the way you would want a kind of website like this to be built.
它基本上是按照您想要的类似网站的方式构建的。
You go on and you get to tell a little bit about what you're looking for and you get a list of therapists and they could be anywhere because this is entirely online.
你继续下去，你可以告诉你一些你正在寻找的东西，你会得到一份治疗师名单，他们可能在任何地方，因为这完全是在线的。
So you have a very large list and they'll tell you about themselves.
所以你有一个非常大的名单，他们会告诉你他们自己。
They have great bios of what brought them to this work, what interests them, what kind of work they've done in the past, what their techniques are, and you get to get a sense of who they are, which is completely different from, you just walk into a therapist's office and you're just meeting this person for the first time, and what's really great about it is you can change, and you could change because the fit isn't quite right, or just actually just recently I changed because it had been a long time with one therapist and I just sort of had a sense that it was time to change, and really makes it so easy to just go.
他们有很好的个人简介，包括他们从事这项工作的原因、他们的兴趣、他们过去做过什么样的工作、他们的技术是什么，你可以了解他们是谁，这完全不同于你走进治疗师的办公室，你只是第一次见到这个人，真正伟大的是你可以改变，你可以改变，因为不合适，或者实际上只是最近我才改变，因为与一个治疗师相处了很长时间。治疗师和我只是有一种感觉，是时候改变了，而且真的让改变变得如此容易。
have your list of therapists and you can just choose whoever you feel is the right fit for you.
拥有您的治疗师名单，您可以选择您认为最适合您的治疗师。
It almost sounds like Rula and I hope they're okay with me saying this.
这听起来几乎像鲁拉，我希望他们同意我这么说。
It's like a Somalia for therapists.
这就像治疗师的索马里。
It is.
这是。
It's exactly what it is.
就是这样。
You've got to start what you're looking for and they say I have a lovely I have a lovely person in Denver Colorado for you.
你必须开始你正在寻找的东西，他们说我在科罗拉多州丹佛有一个可爱的人给你。
That's right and they give you just a little bit at you so take a little sip for at first you just have your one appointment see if it fits And if not, you send it back and you get that next bottle.
是的，他们只会给你一点点，所以先喝一小口，因为一开始你只是有一个约会，看看它是否合适，如果不合适，你就把它寄回去，然后你会得到下一瓶。
And I can attest as Alex's longtime friend.
作为亚历克斯的老朋友，我可以作证。
He used to be a mess, and now he's all he's doing great.
以前他一团糟，现在他一切都很好。
You knew me in the pre-Rula days, those were dark days.
你在鲁拉之前的日子里认识我，那是黑暗的日子。
I don't wish you would pre-rule on anyone.
我不希望你对任何人做出预先裁决。
But they've done great work with you.
但他们和你一起做了很棒的工作。
You're a shining example of what can happen.
你是可能发生的事情的光辉榜样。
Rula helps you find licensed therapists and psychiatrists who truly align with your background in goals rather than just assigning you the first open slot available.
Rula 帮助您找到真正符合您目标背景的有执照的治疗师和精神科医生，而不是仅仅为您分配第一个可用的空缺职位。
Even better, RULA RULA RULA works with over 100 major insurance plans nationwide, bringing the average session copay to just $15.
更好的是，RULA RULA RULA 与全国 100 多个主要保险计划合作，使平均疗程自付额仅为 15 美元。
They support you from day one, tracking your milestones and helping you monitor your care along the way to ensure you are actually moving forward.
他们从第一天起就为您提供支持，跟踪您的里程碑并帮助您全程监控您的护理，以确保您真正取得进展。
Thousands of people are already using RULA to get affordable high-quality therapy That's actually covered by insurance.
成千上万的人已经在使用 RULA 来获得负担得起的高质量治疗，这实际上是由保险承保的。
Visit rulea.com slash your mother to get started.
访问rulea.com 砍掉你的母亲即可开始。
That's rulea-ru-la.com slash your mother.
那是rulea-ru-la.com 砍你妈妈。
You deserve mental health care that works with you, not against your budget.
您应该得到适合您的心理健康护理，而不是违反您的预算。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com Snapple would like you to take a break from the sheds.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。 Snapple 希望您远离棚屋休息一下。
Those things you should be doing, should be finishing, should be thinking about.
那些你应该做、应该完成、应该思考的事情。
right now just uh crack open a snaple and just sit tight for a minute while Craig and I share some snapple real facts with you uh not unlike uh Mr. Mosby's fun facts.
现在，呃，打开一个斯纳普，坐一会儿，克雷格和我与你分享一些斯纳普的真实事实，就像莫斯比先生的有趣事实一样。
Mr. Ted Mosby would have a lot of his fun facts.
特德·莫斯比先生会有很多有趣的事实。
He would love these and some of these are even an architecture related so we give us our first fact.
他会喜欢这些，其中一些甚至与架构相关，所以我们给我们第一个事实。
What do you guys?
你们做什么？
These all feel like things Ted or at least like a future like dad Ted would say.
这些都感觉像是泰德的事情，或者至少像泰德爸爸所说的未来。
All right, here is a Snapple Real Facts 253.
好吧，这是 Snapple 真实事实 253。
The first TV remote control introduced in 1950 was called Lazy Bones.
1950 年推出的第一个电视遥控器被称为“Lazy Bones”。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
I mean, I mean, the real fact of 1517 in New York, it is illegal to sell a haunted house without telling the buyer.
我是说，我是说，1517年纽约的真实事实是，在不告诉买家的情况下出售鬼屋是违法的。
That's actually amazing.
这实际上是惊人的。
And that feels like a very, that feels like a very martial actually.
这感觉就像是一种非常非常武术的感觉。
These are are weirdly resonant.
这些都产生了奇怪的共鸣。
Okay, fact, that is amazing, and I want to know more, but we don't have time for it in the Snapple Chat.
好吧，事实上，这太棒了，我想了解更多，但我们在 Snapple Chat 中没有时间。
Real facts, 1978, 1,978, I'm gonna think, that's nothing to do with the year 1978.
真实的事实，1978年，1,978年，我想，这与1978年无关。
More than 40 buildings in New York have their own zip codes.
纽约有 40 多座建筑物都有自己的邮政编码。
That is totally a Ted Mosby fund.
这完全是泰德·莫斯比基金。
That is.
那是。
He would actually know that.
他实际上会知道这一点。
He told every girl from that.
他告诉每个女孩。
Snapple, real fact, 1,667.
Snapple，真实的事实，1,667。
Lovebirds are actual birds.
爱情鸟是真正的鸟类。
and we bring you back to love.
我们将带您重回爱的怀抱。
It's all full circle, it's all very him yummy.
一切都圆满了，一切都非常美味。
All right, that's your break.
好吧，这是你的休息时间。
Quick fun and just a little unexpected.
快速有趣，只是有点出乎意料。
Next time you hit pause and make a count with Snapple on your next break.
下次您按下暂停键并在下一次休息时使用 Snapple 进行计数。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
It Ted is a complicated character.
泰德是一个复杂的角色。
He's a complicated character to have played because he's the eyes and ears.
他是一个复杂的角色，因为他是眼睛和耳朵。
He's the center of the show.
他是整场演出的中心人物。
He's the person that kind of welcomes the audience in.
他是那种欢迎观众进来的人。
But he was also his own really flawed dimensional character.
但他也是他自己真正有缺陷的维度性格。
and I have found the people who relate to Ted are unbelievably fascinating to me.
我发现与特德有关的人对我来说令人难以置信的着迷。
Just as many women come up to me and say, I'm like Ted as men.
正如许多女性走过来对我说，作为男人，我就像特德一样。
Oh, I love that.
哦，我喜欢那个。
Which is really incredible.
这真是令人难以置信。
Yeah, but just like people who are worried they feel a little too much, Ted was probably a HSPs at a highly sensitive person.
是的，但就像那些担心自己感觉太过分的人一样，特德可能是一个高度敏感的人的 HSP。
I think that's fair to say.
我认为这样说是公平的。
You know, and he just had a big heart, and it sometimes got in the way of social, you know, what was expected of him.
你知道，他只是有一颗宽广的心，有时这会妨碍社交，你知道，人们对他的期望。
But I just, you know, it's an honor to have played someone that kind of raw, right?
但我只是，你知道，能扮演那种原始的人是我的荣幸，对吧？
Whose nerve endings were so exposed.
谁的神经末梢如此暴露。
And it helped me, you know, it helped me become more vulnerable and, you know, disclosed parts of myself that maybe I was embarrassed about that I, that you guys were demanding that they be front and center.
它帮助了我，你知道，它帮助我变得更加脆弱，你知道，它暴露了我自己的一部分，也许我对我感到尴尬，因为你们要求他们站在前面和中心。
And to also like be even at that time, you know, 2005, like to be a publicly vulnerable male.
甚至在那个时候，你知道，2005年，也喜欢成为一个公众面前脆弱的男性。
Yeah.
是的。
It's still carrying risks.
它仍然存在风险。
How about now?
现在怎么样？
How about now, too?
现在也怎么样？
I mean, it's, it carries risks.
我的意思是，它带有风险。
Yeah.
是的。
But it was like a big grave thing you guys asked of me, and I'm, and I'm grateful, and I'm glad that it resonates with people and continues to.
但这就像你们向我提出的一件大事，我很感激，我很高兴它能引起人们的共鸣，并继续下去。
And it's, it's funny.
这很有趣。
But you said about being vulnerable because it was vulnerable to right, too.
但你提到脆弱是因为它也容易受到权利的影响。
Harder and I are these like super emo, like sort of, we are highly sensitive people.
Harder和我都是超级情绪化的人，就像我们是高度敏感的人一样。
We wear our hearts on our sleeves.
我们把我们的心挂在袖子上。
We, you know, we have big dreams like Ted, the creation of the show, when we were 30 years old, that was a far-fetched impossible dream to create the show.
我们，你知道，我们有像 Ted 一样的伟大梦想，创作这个节目，当我们 30 岁的时候，创作这个节目是一个牵强的不可能的梦想。
That was us Ted Moes being all over the place, coming up with some big far-fetched plan that should never have worked out.
那是我们泰德·莫斯到处乱搞，想出了一些根本不应该成功的宏大计划。
To band it rain.
为了带雨。
But somehow it did demanding that it rain, and somehow it worked out, not in all the ways we thought it would, which is the same story for Ted.
但不知何故，它确实要求下雨，而且不知何故，它成功了，但不是以我们想象的所有方式，这对特德来说也是同样的故事。
never goes exactly how you plan, but it becomes beautiful in some different way than you ever could have imagined that was the show.
永远不会完全按照你的计划进行，但它会以某种不同于你想象的方式变得美丽。
What's funny is, Carter and I are very much like that.
有趣的是，卡特和我很像。
Marshall's are really sweet, emotional, open-hearted, warm, softy of a guy.
马歇尔是一个非常可爱、情感丰富、心胸开阔、热情、柔软的人。
He's basically had one, you know, girlfriend who became his wife, and we would get these notes early on sometimes from well-meaning executives.
他基本上有一个，你知道，后来成为他妻子的女朋友，有时我们会很早就从善意的高管那里收到这些笔记。
Early and before the show was launched, probably before we even cast it, but also maybe early in the run where we get these notes.
在节目开播之前，可能是在我们选角之前，但也可能是在节目播出的早期，我们得到了这些笔记。
The characters were so based on us at first, right?
这些角色一开始都是以我们为原型的，对吧？
And then it became like creating it with you guys.
然后就变成了和你们一起创造它。
But at first, it really was us.
但一开始，确实是我们。
And we would get these notes from executives.
我们会从高管那里得到这些笔记。
It would be the effect of like, these guys are just such fucking wimps.
这会产生这样的效果，这些家伙真是他妈的懦夫。
That's how it felt.
就是这样的感觉。
It was just like, we get notes that to the effect of like, no man.
就像我们收到的笔记一样，大意是“没有人”。
would ever.
永远会。
No man would call himself a man.
没有人会称自己为男人。
Self-respecting man would ever behave in this way.
有自尊心的人永远都会这样做。
We're like, um, well, that's based on something that I did.
我们就像，嗯，嗯，这是基于我所做的事情。
And it was really, really weird.
这真的非常非常奇怪。
And I think it was my little glimpse at probably how it felt to you in literally your body, embodying the character.
我认为这可能是我对你身体的感受的一点小小的瞥见，体现了这个角色。
Yeah.
是的。
And you had to sort of carry that.
你必须随身携带它。
The MTV show Jackass, you were doing that with your heart on CBS every Monday night.
MTV 节目《Jackass》，每周一晚上你都会在 CBS 上用心做这件事。
You were just like, what happens if we push Ted's heart off a cliff and a shopping cart?
你就像，如果我们把特德的心推下悬崖和购物车会发生什么？
Let's see what happens.
让我们看看会发生什么。
And it's just like there was kind of a stunt and emotional stunt man quality to that.
这就像有一种特技和情感特技演员的品质。
And you were kind of doing your own stunts.
你有点像在做自己的特技。
Yeah, especially when there's so much confusion between, you know, you know, you play a character especially if it's the first introduction to you.
是的，尤其是当你扮演的角色之间存在如此多的混乱时，特别是如果这是第一次向你介绍的话。
You know, I didn't have a lot of public things, I mean, I had pilots in series that didn't go anywhere and so this is where people kind of met me.
你知道，我没有太多公开的东西，我的意思是，我的系列飞行员没有去任何地方，所以这就是人们遇见我的地方。
So they thought, well, this is who this is, you know, I do remember at the beginning of I think second or third season, but I don't remember which one, but no, no, it was the beginning of third season and you guys wanted to really send Ted and Barney out on a lot of adventures and you started writing Ted as a little more Barneyish in terms of like he was open to like like one night stands and all this stuff.
所以他们想，好吧，这就是这个人，你知道，我确实记得在第二季或第三季的开头，但我不记得是哪一季，但是不，不，那是第三季的开头，你们真的想让泰德和巴尼出去进行很多冒险，然后你们开始把泰德写得更像巴尼风格，因为他对一夜情之类的事情持开放态度。
And I remember Pam told me that you guys got a note that said, you know, there's a lot of Barney's on TV, but there's only one Ted, let's keep him, let's preserve his Tedness or his Mosby-ness.
我记得帕姆告诉我，你们收到一张纸条，上面写着，你知道，电视上有很多巴尼的形象，但只有一个泰德，让我们保留他，让我们保留他的泰德风格或莫斯比风格。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
And we had a lot of really smart, strong female voices from this video on the network who really got the emotion by the show and we're kind of guardians of that.
我们从网络上的这段视频中得到了很多非常聪明、强有力的女性声音，她们真正从节目中感受到了情感，我们是它的守护者。
And that doesn't always happen.
但这并不总是发生。
And that was really nice.
那真是太好了。
And it's not like that fit in with every other show the network at the time, and that was preserved, and it was what was beautiful about the show.
它并不适合当时网络上的所有其他节目，这一点被保留下来，这就是该节目的美丽之处。
And thank God.
感谢上帝。
I want to do a quick little pause and just say, our producer, Alec Lev, are wonderful and heroic producer without whom we wouldn't be doing this show.
我想稍微停顿一下，然后说，我们的制片人亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）是一位出色而英勇的制片人，没有他我们就不会做这个节目。
We'll chime in from time to time with a question or guidance.
我们会不时提出问题或指导。
Thank you guys for bringing me into this, and I'm excited to be on the journey with you.
谢谢你们带我进入这个领域，我很高兴能和你们一起踏上这段旅程。
And yeah, you might hear some questions from me.
是的，你可能会听到我的一些问题。
My first one here, if I could just throw it in, Josh is, why now?
我在这里的第一个，如果我可以把它扔进去，乔希是，为什么现在呢？
Why now?
为什么是现在？
We've had 10 years podcasts have been around.
播客已经存在 10 年了。
You've been thinking about this show and then all of a sudden Craig got the call and then I got the call.
你一直在考虑这个节目，然后突然克雷格接到了电话，然后我也接到了电话。
You'd like to think about this now and I'm wondering what this answer will include your lovely new wife because I'm eager to talk about that spark of it all too.
你现在想考虑一下这个问题，我想知道这个答案将包括你可爱的新妻子，因为我也渴望谈论这一切的火花。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I did get married a year ago, almost exactly a year ago.
嗯，我确实在一年前结婚了，几乎整整一年前。
Congrats.
恭喜。
And I got married at 49, it took me a while to both me, my wife and to almost be ready to get married.
我 49 岁结婚了，我和我的妻子都花了一段时间才准备结婚。
And I had, without going too much into it, I had challenges in relationships.
我在人际关系方面也遇到了挑战，尽管没有过多考虑。
They were never, I found them easy to get into.
他们从来都不是，我发现他们很容易进入。
I found them hard to sustain.
我发现它们很难维持。
Let's just say that.
就这么说吧。
And a lot of that's between me and my therapist.
其中很多是我和我的治疗师之间的事情。
But the journey of becoming the man I who could stand in front of my wife and make that kind of commitment was quite a journey and I felt, you know, and it was different.
但成为一个能够站在妻子面前并做出这种承诺的男人的旅程是一段相当长的旅程，我觉得，你知道，这是不同的。
Like I said, my challenges and relationships were different.
就像我说的，我的挑战和人际关系是不同的。
Like I used to joke with people that say, you know, Ted has to be careful not to get married on the first date, but I had to be careful not to get divorced on the first date.
就像我以前和人们开玩笑说，你知道，特德必须小心不要在第一次约会时结婚，但我必须小心不要在第一次约会时离婚。
That was always like looking for the problem kind of thing, not like falling in love so quickly.
这总是像是在寻找问题之类的事情，而不是像那么快坠入爱河。
But I think there's something about turning 50 having gotten married and just done some work around some of the shadowy aspects of playing Ted being thought of as a person that you're not, you know, some of that was really hard for me.
但我认为，在 50 岁结婚后，我只是做了一些工作，解决了扮演 Ted 时被认为是一个你不是的人的一些阴暗方面，你知道，其中一些对我来说真的很难。
It was really hard to navigate just just in the realm of like identity.
仅仅在相似的身份领域中导航真的很困难。
Like who am I?
比如我是谁？
Who do I self conceive of?
我自己设想的是谁？
Who do I think I am versus like all these people are telling me, you know, that's not your name.
我认为我是谁，而不是像所有这些人告诉我的那样，你知道，那不是你的名字。
Your name is not Josh.
你的名字不是乔希。
You have to be rolling around New York City with 10 party and you are, but March and you are, you know, and it felt like this almost theft of my sense of self, like it was really a challenge.
你必须和 10 个人一起在纽约市闲逛，而你确实是这样，但是马奇和你，你知道，这感觉就像是我的自我意识几乎被偷走了，就像这真的是一个挑战。
But as the years have gone by, the people who say, I had a guy from Turkey yesterday, or two days ago, stop me, came running out of coffee shop to stop me.
但随着时间的流逝，人们说，昨天，或者两天前，我有一个来自土耳其的人，阻止我，从咖啡店跑出来阻止我。
And he said, thank you so much for teaching us to believe in love, to believe in ourselves.
他说，非常感谢你教会我们相信爱，相信我们自己。
That's an amazing thing to hear on like a Tuesday morning and like 11 in the morning.
在周二早上和上午 11 点听到这样的消息真是太棒了。
And Jordana, my wife is really good at making me kind of pinch myself in those moments when she's with me like to say like, do you see that you were a part of something that really moved people.
乔丹娜，我的妻子真的很擅长让我在那些时刻掐自己，当她和我在一起的时候，她会说，你看到了吗，你是真正感动人们的事情的一部分。
So the people who, it's outweighed by, you know, any of that shadowy stuff is outweighed by the people who just say like, you know, like Rob Delaney in his book saying, my wife and I needed to laugh and we watched how I met your mother when our son was sick in the hospital.
所以，那些被那些阴暗的东西所压倒的人，被那些只是说，你知道，就像罗伯·德莱尼在他的书中说的那样的人所压倒，我和我的妻子需要笑，当我们的儿子生病住院时，我们看着我是如何见到你母亲的。
Like, things like that, it's made me almost in like a, like a Jungian way, like to say, all right, there's part of Ted that is, I wrote pretty extensively about this in my newsletter, but maybe a year or two ago, but about Ted's a part of me.
就像这样的事情，它让我几乎以一种荣格的方式，想说，好吧，这是泰德的一部分，也就是说，我在时事通讯中写了相当多的内容，但也许是一两年前，但关于泰德是我的一部分。
He's literally a part I played, but he's not all of me.
他确实是我扮演的一个角色，但他并不是我的全部。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think for a long time, I was like, trying to be like that's not me that's not me like I was in rejection of him But I would not take walls that evoked him and I was really fighting him and I think there's something about the time in my life Right now, and maybe it's just literally the mercy of time That has allowed me to say all right, you know, let's turn around and look at this guy Let's look at this character you played.
我想很长一段时间，我都想表现得不是我，不是我，就像我在拒绝他一样，但我不会接受那些唤起他的围墙，我真的在与他作斗争，我认为我生命中的时间现在有一些东西，也许这只是时间的仁慈，这让我可以说，好吧，你知道，让我们转过身来看看这个人，让我们看看你扮演的这个角色。
Let's look at who you were when you played this character and look I was a different person in 2005 than I was in 2014 and so were you a big time you know a lot yeah change and I'm a lot different now than I was in 2014 yeah so I think it was just it'll there's something allowed me the space and the um grace and the patience with myself to go let's stop running away let's actually this is a part it's gonna be in my obituary a lot of people recognize me from it and still want to talk about it.
让我们看看你扮演这个角色时的样子，看看2005年的我和2014年的我是一个不同的人，所以你是一个伟大的时代，你知道很多是的变化，我现在和2014年的我有很大的不同是的，所以我认为这只是有一些东西给了我空间和嗯恩典和对自己的耐心让我们停止逃跑让我们实际上这是它会在我的一部分很多人从讣告中认出了我，并且仍然想谈论它。
So I was just, I wanted to drop whatever war I had with it and just say, like, all right, how I made my mother, all right, Ted, let's take him, let's, let's bring it in.
所以我只是，我想放弃我与它之间的任何战争，只是说，好吧，我是如何创造我的母亲的，好吧，特德，让我们带上他，让我们，让我们把它带进来。
You know, bring it in.
你知道的，把它带进来。
Let's see what we, let's see what's there.
让我们看看我们有什么，让我们看看那里有什么。
Yeah, it's, and I hope that will make this little exploration, this experiment we're doing of this podcast, sort of universal to people, even if it's not like, himium super fans.
是的，我希望这将使我们对这个播客所做的这个小小的探索、这个实验对人们来说具有普遍性，即使它不像，himium 超级粉丝。
And like, well, I love that the himium super fans will listen, but it's also kind kind of a podcast about figuring out who you were in another chapter and how does it fit in with who you are now.
就像，嗯，我喜欢 Himium 超级粉丝会听，但这也是一种播客，旨在了解你在另一章中是谁，以及它如何与你现在的身份相适应。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, all the grand, all the grand themes of how our mother are at play right now in this podcast and they will be as long as we do it.
我的意思是，我们的母亲现在在这个播客中所扮演的所有宏大、所有宏大的主题，只要我们这样做，它们就会一直存在。
You know, I do hope that there's people who've never watched the show who tune into this podcast and watch it.
你知道，我确实希望有从未看过该节目的人收听该播客并观看它。
Okay.
好的。
Well, that brings me to my point.
嗯，这引出了我的观点。
That brings me to a question.
这让我想到一个问题。
Yeah.
是的。
So Josh and I just played this wonderful chair and another thing that's emerged since how mature mothers, a Josh Radner who's become an amazing musician, singer, songwriter, and I have had the privilege a few times now of playing music with him at these fan-fund-based fundraisers we do for a really important cause that I will talk about at some other point.
所以乔什和我刚刚演奏了这把美妙的椅子和另一件事，因为成熟的母亲们，乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）成为了一位了不起的音乐家、歌手、词曲作者，我和我现在有幸在这些以粉丝基金为基础的筹款活动中与他一起演奏音乐，我们为一个非常重要的事业而做，我将在其他时候谈论这个事业。
And we just did it.
我们就这么做了。
We just did it at Powerie Ballroom, and it sold out a month early because how much your mother fans are the best, as I said.
我们刚刚在 Powerie Ballroom 做了这件事，它提前一个月就卖完了，因为正如我所说，你妈妈的粉丝是最好的。
And two different people there afterwards, two different fans told me they had just watched the series 13 times over.
后来有两个不同的人，两个不同的粉丝告诉我他们刚刚把这个系列看了 13 遍。
They've been watching the math on that.
他们一直在观察这方面的数学计算。
My brain is trying to be 13 times 208 and failing.
我的大脑试图成为 13 乘以 208，但失败了。
I'm an English major.
我是英语专业的。
But it's a lot.
但数量很多。
And I, and thank you for watching it that much.
我，非常感谢您的观看。
I'm, you know, I, I haven't seen it that many times.
我，你知道，我，我没见过那么多次。
I haven't ever watched in a long time.
我已经很久没有看过了。
Here's my question.
这是我的问题。
Tell the fans, tell the people listening.
告诉粉丝，告诉听众。
How many times over has your wife, Jordana, seen how I met your mother?
你的妻子乔丹娜看过多少次我是如何遇见你母亲的？
Wow, so yeah, Jordana, my wife, has seen how I met your mother is zero times.
哇，是的，乔丹娜，我的妻子，零次见过我是如何认识你母亲的。
She's never seen the show, which was probably a help in our courtship.
她从未看过这个节目，这可能对我们的求爱有帮助。
I find this, I just want to say I find this so fascinating.
我发现了这一点，我只是想说我发现这很有趣。
So what's happening here, I just want to lay it out for people.
所以这里发生的事情，我只是想向人们展示。
Part of the reason we're doing this podcast is that you were talking to Jordana about this and saying there's this crazy chapter of my life.
我们做这个播客的部分原因是你和乔丹娜谈论了这件事，并说这是我生命中疯狂的一章。
You don't know anything about it.
你对此一无所知。
You were thrilled, I think, that she didn't know anything about it because she just met you.
我想，你很兴奋，因为她刚刚认识你，所以对此一无所知。
Everything you just said about carrying Ted and wearing Ted on your face, she fell in love with you.
你刚才说的关于带着泰德、把泰德戴在脸上的一切，她都爱上了你。
She did not know what the hell how much your mother was, but still does not, right?
她不知道你妈妈到底多少钱，但还是不知道，对吧？
You haven't started the read.
你还没有开始阅读。
And it's also crazy because she is a TV fan, which is a lot of shows this one, just she missed.
这也很疯狂，因为她是一个电视迷，有很多节目，只是她错过了。
I'm so, one of the experiments of this too is Josh will now sit down and you really like how much your mother in the episode where Ted is dating Stella and Stella has not seen Star Wars and Ted is terrified to what if she watches Star Wars, one of my like, go to my core movies and doesn't like it.
我是这样的，这也是一个实验，乔什现在坐下来，你真的很喜欢你妈妈在泰德和斯特拉约会的那一集，而斯特拉没有看过《星球大战》，而泰德很害怕，如果她看《星球大战》，我喜欢的一部，去看我的核心电影，但不喜欢它，会发生什么。
Do I have to break up with her?
我必须和她分手吗？
Forget that, that faulting high stakes in the moment when we were writing that as Star Wars nerds.
忘记这一点吧，当我们作为《星球大战》书呆子写这篇文章时，那是一种高风险的错误。
But can you imagine the, you're going to sit and watch how much your mother a decade of your life if you're gonna sit and watch that with your wife, is there pressure?
但你能想象一下，如果你和你的妻子一起坐着看你的母亲在你生命中度过了多少十年，会有压力吗？
Will that be a fun watch?
这会是一块有趣的手表吗？
Or will you be sort of side-eyeing or going like is she liking this?
或者你会侧视或者说她喜欢这个吗？
I mean, I'm still fascinated by this.
我的意思是，我仍然对此着迷。
Probably watch her watch it quite a bit.
可能看她看了很多次。
I will say our relationship could withstand her not liking it, but I don't, I suspect she's not going to not like it.
我会说我们的关系可以承受她不喜欢，但我不喜欢，我怀疑她不会不喜欢。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Is that what I mean to say?
这就是我想说的吗？
I'm gonna say yes.
我会说是的。
She's a psychologist and she's incredibly, obviously psychologically attuned, so she will understand the deeper aspects of the show for sure.
她是一名心理学家，而且她在心理上有着令人难以置信的、明显的协调性，所以她肯定会理解这部剧的更深层次的方面。
But we are gonna have a section, we haven't worked out exactly how to do it, but we have a section called Questions and Observations from a clinical psychologist, relationship expert, who's never seen how I met your mother who also happens to be married to Josh.
但我们将会有一个部分，我们还没有确切地弄清楚如何去做，但是我们有一个叫做“问题和观察”的部分，来自一位临床心理学家、关系专家，他从来没有见过我是如何认识你母亲的，她也碰巧嫁给了乔什。
Is that title too catchy?
这标题是不是太吸引人了？
Because that's just, we should get an acronym for it.
因为那只是，我们应该得到它的缩写。
We'll just get an acronym for it and we'll be able to.
我们只要得到它的缩写就可以了。
almost as good as Hwimium.
几乎和 Hwimium 一样好。
Hwimium.
Hwimium。
Yeah.
是的。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I mean, my wife Rebecca, who, and I guess I should have said this sooner, she, she, the two of us are kind of like Marshall and Lily, right?
我的意思是，我的妻子丽贝卡，我想我应该早点说这个，她，她，我们两个有点像马歇尔和莉莉，对吧？
It's we met in Wesleyan University, we were being together that whole time, and we were like the old married couple in our late 20s, and that was part of the impetus of how I miss mother and the characters, the creation of those characters.
我们是在卫斯理大学认识的，我们一直在一起，我们就像是二十多岁的老夫妻，这也是我想念母亲和角色以及创造这些角色的部分动力。
She is so annoyed because she only ever watched every episode once, and she said, here Here's how I watched every episode.
她很生气，因为她每集只看了一次，她说，这就是我每集的观看方式。
It would be Monday night, I would be airing.
那是星期一晚上，我会播出。
You'd be sitting next to me, staring at me, seeing if I laughed at the right spots.
你会坐在我旁边，盯着我看，看看我是否在正确的地方笑了。
You would say, did we sound mix that wrong?
你可能会说，我们的混音听起来是不是错了？
You didn't hear, I think you didn't hear that line because you didn't laugh and she'd be like, I didn't laugh because it wasn't that great.
你没有听到，我想你没有听到那句话，因为你没有笑，她会说，我没有笑，因为那不是那么好。
It's not, it's not all gold.
不，不全是金子。
It's not all gold, dude.
这并不都是金子，伙计。
And I'd ask her like, is the music too hot there compared to the dialogue?
我会问她，与对话相比，音乐是否太热了？
And she'd be like, I don't care.
她会说，我不在乎。
I just want to watch it, stop it.
我只是想看看，别看了。
That was her great, she watched for nine years like that.
那是她的伟大，她就这样看了九年。
and has basically never seen episodes besides that.
除此之外基本上从未看过剧集。
And she has been asking for years, like can we dive back in, can we do the rewatch?
多年来她一直在问，比如我们可以重新投入，我们可以重新观看吗？
And I don't know, for whatever reason, I just didn't, I didn't do it.
我不知道，无论出于什么原因，我只是没有，我没有这样做。
I don't know why.
我不知道为什么。
Maybe I was waiting for a round number.
也许我正在等待一个整数。
I was waiting for these 10s and one of these probably.
我正在等待这 10 枚，可能还有其中一枚。
I know this from watching, you know, films I made, like you stopped thinking about the mix 10 years later.
我通过观看我制作的电影知道了这一点，就像十年后你不再考虑混音一样。
Right.
正确的。
You know, you'll just, the bad joke, that joke could have been funnier.
你知道，你会只是，那个糟糕的笑话，那个笑话本来可以更有趣。
And then you see it later and you're like, that was a good joke.
当你稍后看到它时，你会想，这是一个很好的笑话。
What the fuck?
搞什么鬼？
And this old man, he must did me, fell in love with you, New York City.
而这个老人，他一定是让我爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child, a baby in the house, you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我有一个孩子了，家里有一个婴儿，你知道我觉得做什么很难吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do.
要记得做。
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
Yes, that's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
是的，这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know.
我知道。
And I forget.
我忘了。
Oh, I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog, and myself.
哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So how are we going to solve that problem?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something just quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss, you know, I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，我不会，不需要，不用大惊小怪，你知道，我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes, and so what would solve that problem?
是的，那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, wait, are you talking about, Are you talking about Bavarian meat slow lamb yeager snacks sticks?
哦，等等，你是在说，你是在说巴伐利亚肉慢羊肉耶格小吃棒吗？
We agreed that's what right before we started talking to Zoe said that's what we're going to talk about.
我们一致认为，这就是我们开始与佐伊交谈之前所说的，这就是我们要讨论的内容。
Well this is what I want to talk about.
嗯，这就是我想谈的。
The great tasting Bavarian meat, little lamb yeager snacks sticks, they sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life which is I forget to eat.
美味的巴伐利亚肉，小羊肉耶格尔小吃棒，他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, they're made with real ingredients, slow smoked for bold flavor packed with 9 grams of protein per serving and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们是自然发酵的，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also I have a 19 year old boy, also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home and he loves this stuff.
我还有一个 19 岁的男孩，也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会在家里和家里吃掉我们，而且他喜欢这些东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful.
我非常感激。
We got to sample this.
我们必须对此进行采样。
My son is going to eat it all.
我儿子要把它全部吃掉。
I'm going to have like none of it.
我什么都不会。
Okay.
好的。
It's a snack that keeps up with your day whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds.
无论您是在赶会议还是在给婴儿或 19 岁的孩子喂奶，这款零食都能满足您一天的需要。
You're doing school drop off just trying to finish your to-do list.
你正在放学，只是想完成你的待办事项清单。
a moment to savor something delicious for you or your children and did we mention they're portable toss a few in your glove box your gym bag the diaper bag wherever we have a diaper bag I bet you do two or three of those bad boys pick up a pack today your local grocer or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast use code mother 10 mother 1 0 at checkout for 10% off your first order the variant meat snack sticks great taste zero I could talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother and we do.
为您或您的孩子品尝美味佳肴的时刻，我们有没有提到它们是便携式的，在您的手套箱中扔一些，在您的健身包中，在尿布袋中，无论我们有尿布袋，我敢打赌，您中的两个或三个坏男孩今天会拿起一包，您当地的杂货店或在 bavarianmeats.com 上进货，斜杠播客，在结账时使用代码 mother 10 mother 1 0，在您的第一笔订单中享受 10% 的折扣，变种肉类零食棒极了，味道为零，我可以谈论我如何认识你母亲以及我们如何认识你母亲的每一集。
But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
但当谈到我自己的健康时，我却一无所知。
I'd shrug off low energy or a fitness plateau as just stress, basically guessing about what my body actually needed, but you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
我会把低能量或健身平台视为压力，基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么，但当涉及到你的健康时，你不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website you can choose from a suite of more than a hundred health tests, including micronutrient allergy testosterone fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从一套超过一百种的健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮健康、性健康等等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online than visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试，而不是前往当地实验室核心地点收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
Within days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
几天之内，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
To start your journey, visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code Mother to save up to 15% on select tests.
要开始您的旅程，请访问 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用代码 Mother 在精选测试中节省高达 15% 的费用。
That's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code Mother.
这是 ondemand.labcore.com 斜线 mother 并使用代码 Mother。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
But here's a thing that we were starting to unpack in a talk, but we said, ah, let's save it for the show.
但这是我们在一次演讲中开始解开的一件事，但我们说，啊，让我们把它留到节目中吧。
And we can also dip into this with Carter, but it's so fascinating to me that you guys were the age of the characters you were writing essentially.
我们也可以和卡特一起探讨这个问题，但这对我来说太有趣了，因为你们基本上就是你们所写角色的年龄。
Yeah.
是的。
And yet, it was framed as a flashback from an older wiser man who was offering this kind of wisdom and perspective born of his years of being farther along and being able to look back and contextualize it.
然而，它被认为是一位年长智者的闪回，他提供了这种智慧和观点，这些智慧和观点源于他多年来的走得更远，能够回顾过去并将其置于背景中。
and so you were having to, from inside of the experience, you were having to almost beam your consciousness forward 20 or 25 years, and reflect back on the moment you were in.
所以你不得不，从经历的内部，你不得不几乎将你的意识向前投射 20 或 25 年，并反思你所处的那一刻。
Which is like a heroic amount to ask, I think, of anyone much less, you know, young kids running their first TV show, like were you conscious of the weirdness of that?
我认为，这对任何人来说都是一个英雄般的要求，更不用说，你知道，小孩子们正在播放他们的第一个电视节目，就像你意识到这很奇怪吗？
It seems weirder now, in a way, it almost didn't seem that weird at the time and I think it's because we fancied ourselves older than our years.
现在看来更奇怪了，在某种程度上，当时看起来几乎没有那么奇怪，我认为这是因为我们幻想自己比实际年龄更老。
I think, yeah, we were like 32 writing 52 or something, right?
我想，是的，我们就像 32 岁写 52 岁之类的，对吧？
When we were writing, thinking about future Ted's perspectives and he's in his mid 50s, whatever he is, we're now far closer to that and I look back at it and I do think it had something to do with wanting, being drawn to the idea of reassurance of the future.
当我们写作时，思考特德对未来的看法，他已经 50 多岁了，无论他是什么，我们现在离那个目标已经很近了，我回顾起来，我确实认为这与想要、被对未来的保证的想法所吸引有关。
There's a future you, because you feel so lost when you're 30, right?
未来的你是有的，因为30岁的时候你会感到很失落，对吗？
You're not actually quite an adult, right?
其实你还没有成年，对吧？
we were all felt like frauds, we were all the same age, we're all these little kids, we somehow fooled our way into having a TV show, and like we, I think we were just imagining our future selves telling us what we wanted to hear now in this moment because we felt lost, because we felt scared, because we felt haunted.
我们都觉得自己像个骗子，我们都是同样的年龄，我们都是小孩子，我们不知何故欺骗了自己的方式去看电视节目，就像我们一样，我想我们只是想象未来的自己告诉我们现在想听到什么，因为我们感到失落，因为我们感到害怕，因为我们感到困扰。
And that idea of that future Ted gave us so much confidence.
特德对未来的想法给了我们很大的信心。
Like it just sort of lifted us up to be looking through that lens, me by pretending to be that thing, we sort of became that thing.
就像它只是让我们通过那个镜头来观察一样，我假装是那个东西，我们就变成了那个东西。
That's so great.
那太好了。
Now we're sort of the age, almost the age of the of future Ted, and I still feel just about as confused as I ever did about life.
现在我们已经到了这个时代，几乎是未来泰德的时代，但我仍然像以前一样对生活感到困惑。
But I feel a little older and a little wiser.
但我感觉自己老了一些，也聪明了一些。
And I think another big part of it was we were aware, we were, Carter and I, we were big thinkers, we're overthinkers, and we were very aware that a chapter of our lives had ended.
我认为另一个重要原因是我们意识到，卡特和我，我们是伟大的思想家，我们是过度思考者，我们非常清楚我们生命中的一个章节已经结束了。
The 20s in New York part had ended.
20 世纪 20 年代的纽约部分已经结束。
We were writers for David Letterman and we made this leap and this will be a very heavy thing to bring up and talking about a sitcom.
我们是大卫·莱特曼的编剧，我们实现了这一飞跃，提起和谈论情景喜剧将是一件非常沉重的事情。
But we, you know, 9-11 happened a little bit before, like that happened right before we moved to LA.
但我们，你知道，9-11 事件发生过一段时间，就像我们搬到洛杉矶之前发生的那样。
And there was just this feeling in New York City sort of writ large that something had ended.
纽约市有一种明显的感觉，似乎有些事情已经结束了。
Some era had ended.
某个时代已经结束了。
Something had changed that was not going to change back.
有些东西已经改变了，而且不会再变回来。
And then we found ourselves living in Los Angeles trying to think of a pilot idea to write.
然后我们发现自己住在洛杉矶，试图想出一个写作的试点想法。
And we wrote about this nostalgia for our 20s in New York when we were like 30 and one day old.
我们写了关于我们 20 多岁时在纽约的怀旧之情，当时我们才 30 岁零一天。
We didn't mean we were nostalgic for our 20s in New York immediately.
我们并不是说我们会立即怀念 20 多岁的纽约时光。
And but nostalgic for like a time before this horrible tragedy hadn't happened.
但怀念这可怕的悲剧没有发生之前的一段时光。
We were still writing for Letterman when 9-11 happened.
9·11 事件发生时，我们还在为莱特曼写作。
And then we left to move to LA the spring after that, like the spring 2002.
然后我们在第二年春天搬到了洛杉矶，比如 2002 年春天。
I just think the sort of gravitas and the instant requirement to become more of a grown-up from living through 9-11 in New York and the instant nostalgia and the desire to sort of have things make sense or be back in some simpler time and have it a different time in your brain and your memories when things didn't feel the way they felt after 9-11.
我只是觉得，在纽约经历了9·11事件后，那种庄重感和对变得更加成熟的即时要求，以及瞬间的怀旧和渴望让事情变得有意义，或者回到某个更简单的时代，让你的大脑和记忆中的时间与9·11之后的感觉不同。
And I think that weirdly really informed the show.
我认为这确实奇怪地告诉了这部剧。
It made us like maybe a little older than our years and it made us a little more reflective, a little more nostalgic.
它让我们感觉自己比实际年龄老了一点，也让我们更加反思，更加怀旧。
And I think part of that is how we accessed writing from that future perspective, even when we were in our thirties and were pretending to be the old wise guy.
我认为部分原因在于我们如何从未来的角度进行写作，即使我们已经三十多岁了，假装自己是个老智者。
But somehow we could sort of fake our way into being that, at least on paper.
但不知何故，我们可以假装成为这样的人，至少在纸面上是这样。
And I sometimes people will quote months from future, tend to me and say that got them through a really hard time.
有时人们会引用未来几个月的内容，关注我并说这让他们度过了一段非常艰难的时期。
Thank you for those wise words.
谢谢你那些明智的话。
And I'm thinking, we were like 31 wishing we had that.
我在想，我们就像 31 岁的人一样希望能拥有这样的东西。
wisdom and sort of like play acting it, but it works somehow, right?
智慧，有点像演戏，但它以某种方式起作用，对吧？
It feels to me like, like Kenneth Brown out at 31 playing Lear and you're like, what are you doing?
对我来说，就像 31 岁的肯尼思·布朗 (Kenneth Brown) 出演《李尔王》一样，你会想，你在做什么？
Right.
正确的。
But also, it's like, he's good at it.
但同时，他也很擅长。
Right.
正确的。
And it sort of, and does it, does it elevate you?
这有点，确实，它提升了你的水平吗？
It's sort of that idea of like the fake until you make a thing, like it somehow it elevated us and made us feel like we really were that older, was it?
这有点像假货，直到你做出了一件东西，就像它以某种方式提升了我们，让我们感觉自己真的那么老了，是吗？
You know, speaking of Jordan, who it seems like we'll be talking about a bit, she has a thing which she'll sometimes say to her patients.
你知道，说到乔丹，我们似乎会稍微谈论一下她，她有时会对她的病人说一些话。
If someone's really confused, really tied in knots about something, she'll say, what is your 85 year old self say?
如果有人真的很困惑，真的对某事纠结不已，她会说，你85岁的自己会说什么？
She's gonna like him, yeah.
她会喜欢他的，是的。
She's gonna like the show.
她会喜欢这个节目的。
Yeah, but if it's a great question, and she said, if you ask yourself, what is my 85 year old self, the answer comes real fast, and it's real service.
是的，但如果这是一个很好的问题，她说，如果你问自己，我 85 岁的自己是什么样的，答案很快就会到来，而且这是真正的服务。
Yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的。
I think, you know, I mentioned this in that piece I wrote about Ted for my muse letters, but Dick Schwartz has this thing, Internal Family Systems, IFS, which is like really, it's called parts work and you're locating these parts of yourself that are sometimes at odds with each other, but they're all in you.
我想，你知道，我在为我的缪斯信写的关于泰德的那篇文章中提到了这一点，但迪克施瓦茨有这个东西，内部家庭系统，IFS，这就像真的，它被称为部分工作，你正在定位自己的这些部分，有时彼此不一致，但它们都在你身上。
And it strikes me that you and Carter, like, and me too, we have an elder in us.
让我印象深刻的是，你和卡特，还有我，我们心中都有一位长辈。
We have an older, I don't know if it's ancestral or just a wise old, something connected more towards the bigger picture, the perennial kind of wisdom, and we can go there.
我们有一个更年长的人，我不知道它是祖传的还是只是一个智慧的老人，与更大的图景、永恒的智慧有更多的联系，我们可以去那里。
We can access it at 31 or 30 whenever you guys were writing.
当你们写作时，我们可以在 31 或 30 访问它。
The other thing that, I don't know if it was you or Carter, but first season, what year was older Ted narrating, 2030?
另一件事是，我不知道是你还是卡特，但是第一季，泰德叙述的是哪一年，2030 年？
2030, yeah.
2030 年，是的。
2030.
2030年。
So one of you guys said it's actually the most optimistic show in the world because it's saying the world will still be here in 2030.
所以你们中的一个人说这实际上是世界上最乐观的节目，因为它说世界到 2030 年仍然会这样。
Like they'll still be fathers talking to their kids in 2030.
就像到 2030 年他们仍然是父亲一样与孩子交谈。
Yeah.
是的。
No. We and we would make the joke because it is inspiring to think of and then we'd make the joke.
不。我们会开这个玩笑，因为想到这一点很鼓舞人心，然后我们就会开这个玩笑。
But also like we can end the series where you realize like Ted is telling future Ted is telling his kids that story like a mile underground the surface of the earth and I mean he's gonna get the shelter.
但就像我们可以结束这个系列一样，你会意识到泰德正在告诉未来泰德正在告诉他的孩子们这个故事，就像地球表面地下一英里一样，我的意思是他会得到庇护所。
The surface and it's just like the machines of risen up and killed us.
表面就像机器一样起来杀死了我们。
But yeah, we like that idea, there will always be future you there to tell your story.
但是，是的，我们喜欢这个想法，未来总会有你在那里讲述你的故事。
There's a future version of you to whom this all makes more sense, and that is just so much more generous and has such gratitude for even the low moments looking back.
对未来的你来说，这一切都更有意义，而且更加慷慨，即使回顾过去的低潮时刻，也会充满感激之情。
Yeah.
是的。
I think the thing you're describing that I think opened my heart the most to the series, I don't know how much I sense from the pilot, but I think it's all there.
我认为你所描述的事情最让我对这个系列敞开心扉，我不知道我从试播集中感受到了多少，但我认为一切都在那里。
The DNA of the whole show is in the pilot, which we'll be unpacking.
整个节目的 DNA 都在试播集中，我们将对其进行解压。
But it's a fundamentally optimistic show at its core.
但这本质上是一部乐观的剧。
It is not a nihilistic, cynical show, it's a show about decent people, and even Barney who's like somewhat of a sociopathic criminal based on whatever episode he's in has a core of sweetness about him.
这不是一部虚无主义、愤世嫉俗的节目，它是一部关于正派人的节目，甚至巴尼，无论他在哪一集，都像一个反社会的罪犯，他的核心是甜蜜的。
And the way Neil played it kind of with a wink that maybe helped him get away, you guys all get away with a lot.
尼尔眨眼的方式可能帮助他逃脱，你们都逃脱了很多。
But it's a fundamentally optimistic show and I just I liked being both for professional reasons but more almost like for personal reasons, like I'm really conscious of what I'm putting into the collective.
但这从根本上来说是一个乐观的节目，我只是出于职业原因而喜欢两者，但更像是出于个人原因，就像我真的很清楚自己为集体付出了什么。
Like I want and how I made your mother made some missteps and stumbles and we're going to unpack all of those.
就像我想要的那样，以及我如何让你母亲犯下一些错误和绊脚石，我们将解开所有这些。
But generally, I felt like it's feet were pointed in a really good direction and it's heart was in the right place.
但总的来说，我觉得它的脚指向了一个非常好的方向，它的心脏也处于正确的位置。
Also, how narratively invented it was, you know, there was something like 40 to 60 scenes in an average time.
另外，它的叙事性如何，你知道，平均时间内有 40 到 60 个场景。
The record was 83.
记录是83。
In 21 minutes, 21 and a half minutes, basically, you're doing 81 scenes or 60 scenes or 50 scenes, like it's a lot of...
基本上，在 21 分钟、21 分钟半的时间里，你会拍 81 个场景、60 个场景或 50 个场景，就像很多......
Alec, you have a question.
亚历克，你有一个问题。
By the way, I will say Alec Lev is chiming in a little comment.
顺便说一下，我想说亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）正在插话。
Alec worked on the show multiple seasons as our new media coordinator.
亚历克作为我们的新媒体协调员参与了该剧多个季的工作。
He did the in production podcast, which we did for a few years on the show and he did all the sort of internet presence and DVD extras and all the stuff.
他制作了制作中的播客，我们在节目中做了几年，他还制作了所有的互联网节目和 DVD 附加节目以及所有的东西。
So Alec is also a himium alum, which I failed to say.
所以Alec也是一名hiium明矾，这一点我没有说出来。
Alec, what do you want to say?
亚历克，你想说什么？
And you and I also shared a cat.
你和我还共用一只猫。
We went to college and lived together all four years.
我们上大学并一起生活了四年。
And one time I was hanging out with Alec and a bunch of people and he said, he introduced me forgetting that we went to college together.
有一次我和亚历克以及一群人一起出去玩，他说，他介绍我时忘记了我们一起上过大学。
He started explaining what Wesleyan is.
他开始解释卫斯理安是什么。
He said to And other people that we were standing with, they went to us and was like, we all went to college together.
他对我们站在一起的其他人说，他们走向我们，就像我们一起上大学一样。
I was there.
我在那里。
You don't have to tell me that.
你不必告诉我这一点。
Alex, go ahead.
亚历克斯，继续吧。
Well, no, I just want to, so this podcast, I want to hear a little bit as we wrap up this first episode of what people can expect from this version of a rewatch podcast.
好吧，不，我只是想，所以在这个播客中，当我们结束第一集时，我想听听一些关于人们可以从这个版本的重播播客中期待什么的内容。
If you've heard other ones where people go episode by episode, we are going to do that next week.
如果您听说过其他节目，人们会逐集观看，我们将在下周这样做。
You're going to hear Carter Bay.
你会听到卡特贝的声音。
lot about Carter.
关于卡特的很多事情。
Carter's going to join us to talk about the creation of how I met your mother and all these questions that you guys have been asking.
卡特将和我们一起谈论我如何认识你母亲的故事以及你们一直在问的所有这些问题。
And then from there, we'll be going episode by episode because you talk a little bit about what people are going to hear that you know of, because of course, we don't quite know where we're going exactly, but Josh, tell us a little bit about what's coming up.
然后从那里开始，我们将一集接着一集，因为你会谈论一些你知道的人们会听到的内容，因为当然，我们不太知道我们到底要去哪里，但是乔希，告诉我们一些即将发生的事情。
Yeah, I know this is a big fun trend that people are really liking these these rewatch podcasts, I have to confess, I've never listened to a single one of them.
是的，我知道这是一个很有趣的趋势，人们真的很喜欢这些重看播客，我必须承认，我从来没有听过其中的一个。
I don't know, I know it's happening, I don't know what other people are doing.
我不知道，我知道它正在发生，我不知道其他人在做什么。
I just know what I like to talk about with Craig.
我只知道我喜欢和克雷格谈论什么。
I have, and Craig has some special insight into this particular show.
我有，克雷格对这个特殊的节目有一些特殊的见解。
I think that some episodes will be more very specifically about the episode.
我认为有些剧集会更具体地讲述该剧集。
I imagine when we get to drum roll, please, right?
我想当我们开始击鼓时，好吗？
will talk very deeply about that episode.
将非常深入地谈论那一集。
It's a pretty iconic one.
这是一个非常具有标志性的。
I remember I think this is true that they could analyze the data like once it went up maybe on Netflix and Drumroll, please, was the one that was the hookiest episode.
我记得我认为这是真的，他们可以分析数据，就像在 Netflix 和 Drumroll 上发布的数据一样，拜托，这是最吸引人的一集。
It was the one that made people want to watch more or something, I don't know.
我不知道，正是它让人们想看更多或其他东西。
That's right.
这是正确的。
But then there are other ones that maybe are a little less dense that might just inspire another talk.
但还有其他一些可能不太密集的内容可能会激发另一场讨论。
So if you're tuning in with us, You're going to hear a lot of talk about how I'm going to learn, but you're also going to hear us muse about different things, you know, different, I want us to be open to talk about our own lives, to talk about, it's not going to be super current, a faresy because I think like one of the things I love about how I made other mother is the part of it that ages well in terms of, you know, it wasn't, there wasn't a lot of tech in how I made, I mean, is things that that will be perennially relevant, right?
所以如果你和我们一起收听，你会听到很多关于我将如何学习的讨论，但你也会听到我们思考不同的事情，你知道，不同的，我希望我们能够开放地谈论我们自己的生活，谈论，这不会是超级流行的，一个奇幻的事情，因为我认为我喜欢的一件事是我如何成为另一个母亲，这是它的一部分，它很古老，你知道，它不是，那里我的制作方式并没有太多技术，我的意思是，那些东西会永远相关，对吗？
So I think we if you want to watch a long or re-watch along with us, there's going to be a lot of talk about certain episodes, certain jokes, where it came to funny off-stage anecdotes, anecdotes, inside baseball stuff that will be really fun for the Superfan, but also I hope it's just a fun, you know, getting to spend some time with us, you know, in a way that feels nourishing and insightful and just like a breezy good time, you know.
所以我认为，如果你想和我们一起看很长一段时间或重新观看，将会有很多关于某些剧集、某些笑话的讨论，其中涉及到有趣的台下轶事、轶事、棒球内部的东西，这对超级粉丝来说真的很有趣，但我也希望这只是一种乐趣，你知道，和我们一起度过一些时间，你知道，以一种感觉滋润和富有洞察力的方式，就像一段轻松愉快的时光，你知道。
Yeah, and I think there's going to be some looking back with different eyes.
是的，我认为会有一些人以不同的眼光回顾过去。
I think there'll be some owning of some moments that didn't age as well, even though I hope the show is timeless.
我认为，尽管我希望这部剧是永恒的，但也会有一些不那么古老的时刻。
I think there's going to be some a few like apologies to people whose stories we stole without asking.
我认为对于那些我们未经询问就窃取了故事的人，将会有一些类似的道歉。
I was terrible at that.
我对此感到很糟糕。
I would just take people's life stories.
我只会拍摄人们的生活故事。
If they're like, that's funny.
如果他们是这样的话，那就有趣了。
Put it on TV and then I wouldn't tell the person that it's in TV.
把它放在电视上，然后我不会告诉那个人它在电视上。
Until they saw it.
直到他们看到了。
What the hell's going on here?
这到底是怎么回事？
If you're wondering where he got the idea for a married couple sharing a toothbrush, tune it.
如果你想知道他从哪里得到了一对已婚夫妇共用牙刷的想法，那就调整一下吧。
We'll, we'll, we'll, we'll dive into that one.
我们会，我们会，我们会，我们会深入研究这个问题。
Spoilers, it's all like, I mean, let's just, let's just, let's just go there.
剧透，我的意思是，我们就这样，我们就这样，我们就去那里吧。
Why are we going to wait?
我们为什么要等待？
Someone watched it and said, it's pronounced chameleon.
有人看了就说，这叫变色龙。
Oh my God, I definitely want to talk about that one.
天哪，我绝对想谈谈这个。
But yeah, yeah, I think it's going to, it's going to be fun.
但是，是的，是的，我认为这会很有趣。
It's going to be fun to look back on it.
回顾起来会很有趣。
And sometimes it'll be very much about the episode.
有时它会与剧集有关。
sometimes a little spears, like what did the topic of that episode make us think about at the time and now and how do we look at it now and how much, you know, I want to talk also about like what of our lives at the time made it onto the show and what it was happening in our own personal lives that informed the show, like I, yeah, I went through a lot during how I met your mother as did we all in nine years you go through a lot of stuff and basically 10 years door to door and yeah, I want to talk about that stuff and also how you as writers start paying attention very keenly to us as actors and how that changes how you write the character.
有时会有一些小矛，比如那一集的主题让我们当时和现在思考什么，我们现在如何看待它，你知道，我也想谈谈我们当时的生活是什么进入了节目，以及我们自己的个人生活中发生的事情为节目提供了信息，就像我，是的，我在遇见你母亲的过程中经历了很多，就像我们在九年里经历了很多事情一样，基本上是十年挨家挨户，是的，我想谈谈这些东西，以及你作为作家如何开始非常敏锐地关注我们作为演员，以及这如何改变你写角色的方式。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, there were certain things.
你知道，有一些事情。
I remember, I remember like sometimes you'll get a big laugh at a run through like a network run through and I'll just be like, oh, they're going to.
我记得，我记得有时你会因为像网络一样的运行而大笑，我会说，哦，他们会这么做的。
And I remember when I walked in return of the shirt, which for some reason I have very big fondness for, but when I walked in and Marshall said, hot top, bro, do you remember that?
我记得当我走回那件衬衫时，出于某种原因，我非常喜欢这件衬衫，但当我走进去时，马歇尔说，热上衣，兄弟，你还记得吗？
And I just said, right, right.
我只是说，对，对。
And for some reason, right, right became a kind of, it was like a catchphrase.
由于某种原因，对，对成为一种，就像一个流行语。
It was a low key catchphrase.
这是一个低调的口号。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And I think that was one of the first times I said, but I remember people just, I say that all the time, just like laughed so hard as they're right, right?
我想这是我第一次这么说，但我记得人们，我一直这么说，就像笑得很厉害，因为他们是对的，对吧？
We did that all the time.
我们一直都是这么做的。
That is a, like, if that, that's a low key in your catchphrase, I'm glad you put it that would not.
这是一个，就像，如果那样，这是你的口号中的低调，我很高兴你说不会。
I definitely still say that.
我肯定还是这么说。
And that was, that was your, did you improvise that?
那是，那是你的，是你即兴创作的吗？
I don't feel like we wrote, did we write?
我不觉得我们写过，我们写过吗？
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
I have, we might have written it, but I have one in my mind.
我有，我们可能已经写了，但我心里有一个。
People say, did you ever write on the show?
人们问，你在节目中写过文章吗？
And I said, one line.
我说，一行。
And it was, I dropped, what was the thing where I had to climb in the mailbox?
是的，我掉了下来，我必须爬进邮箱的东西是什么？
And I got stuck in the mailbox.
我被困在邮箱里了。
What was that?
那是什么？
I'm literally blanking on what the context of the New York street.
我真的对纽约街道的背景感到茫然。
And I dropped in a letter to the mailbox.
我把一封信投到了邮箱里。
And then I realized I needed to get it out.
然后我意识到我需要把它拿出来。
I shouldn't have mailed it.
我不应该邮寄它。
But I, I remember I, I, I, I did the rehearsal and I went up to either you or Carter whoever was on set.
但我，我记得我，我，我，我排练过，然后我走向你或卡特，无论是谁在片场。
And I said, can I drop it in and say mailed it?
我说，我可以把它放进去并说邮寄吗？
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
That was my one big improv that made it.
这是我做出的一大改进。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I just speak that.
我只是说说而已。
I feel like there were many more than that.
我感觉还有很多。
But that's a good maybe, maybe.
但这也许是件好事。
So I just want to add here about all the ways that listeners can interact with the show because from the very beginning, you've both been saying you want this very much to be a show for not just for the fans, but sort of buy them as well.
所以我只想在这里补充一下听众与节目互动的所有方式，因为从一开始，你们就一直在说，你们非常希望这不仅是一场为粉丝而做的节目，而且也为他们买单。
And if you go to our website, how we made your mother.com, you're going to find a way that you can send us a message and tell us your story.
如果您访问我们的网站，了解我们如何创建您的 mother.com，您将找到一种可以向我们发送消息并告诉我们您的故事的方式。
And you can tell us a story just about how I met your rather in general, or there's even ways for you to talk about specific episodes, send in an audio message to us, like you heard at the beginning of this show, you can also write us a message, and we'll read a lot of those, like a lot of them, like we really want to hear from you.
你可以告诉我们一个关于我如何认识你的故事，或者你甚至可以通过一些方式来谈论特定的情节，向我们发送音频消息，就像你在这个节目开始时听到的那样，你也可以给我们写一条消息，我们会读很多这样的消息，就像很多这样，就像我们真的很想收到你的消息一样。
Also, the home of this show online is really going to be on Substack, and you can find a link to that on our website, Josh is on Substack, and you can read his newsletters, and then you'll also be able to read about the show.
另外，这个在线节目的主页确实会在 Substack 上，你可以在我们的网站上找到该链接，Josh 在 Substack 上，你可以阅读他的时事通讯，然后你也可以阅读有关该节目的信息。
Josh and Craig are going to write a little bit about each episode.
乔什和克雷格将针对每一集写一些内容。
You'll get the show notes there and maybe other ways to interact and of course we're all over social media.
您会在那里获得演出笔记，也许还有其他互动方式，当然我们都在社交媒体上。
So if you just go over to howwemadeyourmother.com, you're going to find all of those ways to be a part of how we made your mother.
因此，如果您访问 howwemadeyourmother.com，您就会发现所有这些方法都可以成为我们创造您母亲的一部分。
Yeah, and we really want to encourage people to kind of like join the community of this thing and and kind of, you know, collect an archive of them like this is, this is what the show is and was and remains to us.
是的，我们真的想鼓励人们加入这个东西的社区，并且，你知道，收集他们的档案，就像这样，这就是这个节目现在、过去和现在对我们来说的样子。
But we love the idea of you guys feeling like it's us doing this, but you're with us.
但我们喜欢这样的想法：你们感觉是我们在做这件事，但你们和我们在一起。
Participate, join us, tell your friends, we're really excited.
参与、加入我们、告诉您的朋友，我们真的很兴奋。
We're soliciting testimonials about how I met your mother and what it's meant to people.
我们正在征求有关我如何认识你母亲以及这对人们意味着什么的评价。
We really want this to be a feature of the show.
我们真的希望这成为该剧的一个特色。
We want to hear from you out there how you discovered the show, what it's meant to you.
我们想听听您是如何发现这个节目的，它对您意味着什么。
So I'm just going to read one because maybe we'll make this a regular feature.
所以我只想读一篇，因为也许我们会让它成为一项常规功能。
But this one says, hey, Josh, I'm sending you this message from France.
但这个人说，嘿，乔什，我从法国给你发了这条消息。
I don't know if you really love being recognized as Ted Mosby, but today I want to talk to you about it.
我不知道你是否真的喜欢被称为 Ted Mosby，但今天我想和你谈谈这个问题。
I need to talk to you about it because tonight for the third time I finished how I met your mother and for the third time I cried a lot.
我需要和你谈谈这件事，因为今晚我第三次讲完我是如何遇见你母亲的，第三次我哭了很多。
I'm 17 and I really grew up watching this series And I mean in every way possible.
我今年 17 岁，我真的是看着这个系列长大的，我的意思是在所有可能的方面。
I went through a lot of very bad times and you were always there to make me laugh and believe again, you were there to instruct me really important things about life.
我经历了很多非常糟糕的时光，你总是在那里让我开怀大笑，让我再次相信，你在那里指导我关于生活的真正重要的事情。
Every episode had something to teach me.
每一集都有一些东西可以教给我。
Like, I just like your character believe a lot in destiny, maybe too much.
就像，我只是喜欢你的性格，相信命运，也许太多了。
I love too much.
我太爱了。
I do everything too much.
我做的一切都太多了。
And sometimes I'm worrying if I shouldn't just stop.
有时我会担心我是否不应该停下来。
But thanks to how I met your mother, I'll never worry again because this is me and I'm never gonna change.
但多亏了我认识你母亲的方式，我再也不会担心了，因为这就是我，我永远不会改变。
I'll still be me forever.
我永远还是我。
So what I wanna say is a big thank you, Josh, for everything.
所以我想说的是，非常感谢乔什，为我所做的一切。
By the way, I listened to your songs and they are legend, wait for it, Derry.
顺便说一句，我听过你的歌曲，它们都是传奇，等等，德里。
So that's awesome.
所以这太棒了。
Alec picked that one.
亚历克选了那个。
I don't want it to seem like I was like, let's pick the one where they mentioned my music.
我不想让别人觉得我在想，让我们选一个他们提到我的音乐的吧。
Oh.
哦。
Ha ha ha.
哈哈哈。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins off again.
一切罪孽再次消散。
New York City!
纽约市！
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Webb 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point de Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯。
Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表了散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《已故父亲协会》(Dead Fathers Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下得以实现，营销由 Tink Media 提供。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
The real question, it just hit me.
真正的问题，它刚刚击中了我。
Am I in love with you or just new York City?
我爱的是你还是只爱纽约市？
Well, Craig, thank you for chatting with me, my friend.
好吧，克雷格，谢谢你和我聊天，我的朋友。
Oh, this is a delay.
噢，这就是延迟。
This is a delay.
这是一个延迟。
If not one person listens, I'm still having a really good time, but I don't know.
如果没有人听，我仍然过得很开心，但我不知道。
Let's do it 220 more times.
让我们再做 220 次。
Let's do it at least three times thirteen.
我们至少做三遍十三次。
Yeah, but it's it's like to spend time with you and Alec and I'm excited to unpack this stuff and it feels honestly it feels like Psychologically healthy for me to do this, you know, it feels like are you ready to go back to the Titanic?
是的，但这就像与你和亚历克共度时光，我很高兴能打开这些东西，老实说，这样做对我来说感觉心理健康，你知道，感觉就像你准备好回到泰坦尼克号了吗？
It's got a kind of quality of that, but I am, you know, let's do it
它有这样的品质，但我，你知道，让我们这样做吧